the 2018 Sinquefield cub was really
fascinating because it was extremely
competitive but for different reasons
than the 2017 Zingo cub we were kept on
the edge of our seat for the very very
last move of the last round up to that
point there was a lot of draws we were
getting antsy memories we you know we
were just spoiled and we're used to
seeing so many victories in the
Sinquefield Cup and there was just a lot
of draws and a big point with that was
Norway chess had happened earlier in the
exactly Wow and there were a lot of
draws there when we were thinking oh the
CFL Cup is gonna be the one to show you
real fighting chess because we're used
to it
cantankerous fights happening breaking
out everywhere in this in this event but
it didn't happen
no yeah there were nip and tuck affairs
everywhere not for want of trying but
the players were just so good and
neutralizing each other indeed trench
warfare when you think about the carpeau
vien way of winning a tournament we all
understand it's you get a few wins no
losses no losses very important to go
undefeated well it's very rare at the
very highest levels that you have say
two players going undefeated three
players no no just doesn't happen in
2018 we had six players out of ten who
went undefeated it was because two
players were doing terribly at the
bottom there there was Sergei and there
was Hikaru struggling and then everybody
else was taking one victory and just
holding on to it and maybe two victories
and that's what made it so dramatic the
final round but you know you talk about
that because the topic of draws start
coming up and people horse brought it up
to us what are you gonna do about all
these draw how do you get the players to
fight well it's a conflict right because
I'm so full of admiration for these
great players in their ability to hold
these difficult positions and to defeat
these 2800 s well you see it's
is getting harder and harder so on the
one hand I really admire the fact that
these guys just they don't lose they
just tough there's the toughest nails
and then on the other hand but wait a
minute we want to see blood we want to
see those victories and those great
attacks and these guys are playing
defensive combinations before you're
even a warrior you had an attacking
possibility so that makes it tough but
hey it's Jess it's Jess and the players
are trying really really hard Louise and
you can see it at the board their
expressions and I tell you I love the
guy hikaru he just wears his expressions
you know openly suffering no but no 2018
was a bad event for Hikaru but it was a
first time that we had three players
time for first well as we get to that
right Magnus wins early and they
subsequently draws a ton of games in a
row right Aronian wins early and
subsequently draws a ton of games in a
row Bobby wins in the middle rounds four
and six
he gets his wind and takes the lead so
and he holds on to he's plus one going
into that he's plus two plus one on the
field going into that final round right
he's got two points he's got plus two
magna Scott has plus one going into the
last round Aronian has plus one going
into the last round and my Madeira is
that plus one going into the last round
is right who's going to catch Fabi right
then we get the dramatic final round
well it's not only who's gonna catch
Valle well maybe Fabia's got his destiny
he can deal with it right here right now
and we could have yet again another
clean winner for the Sinquefield Cup
first repeat winner it would be by the
way right because nobody had repeated up
until that time but no he does draw and
he does give an opening an opportunity
for himself to be caught
shot doesn't do it but LaVon has to be
Sasha and if he can do it he wins or
tight
first and then the cake that just kept
us in the poof forever and ever was
magnus versus akaru
and that rook ending and it was like I
can't describe it any better than
imagining a slow-motion train wreck you
thought to yourself no they're not going
to car is not gonna lose this game I
mean it's a rook ending and it's equal
he's worse but he's gonna drop and then
slowly you know it's just like a water
torture move after move after move
Magnus keeps increasing the pressure he
wins upon he's he's improving he's
improving and then suddenly it's gone
Oh Magnus style by the way at least test
it the Magnus they knew from years ago
given his best and given that he had not
won Super tournaments exactly even
struggling to win these super tournament
this was a very big deal to him to win
and to show that he could win yet again
and prove to everybody that he is indeed
the Magnus Carlsen that we know is a
killer well and he exposed that himself
at the closing ceremony where he spoke
with great joy beaming happiness
boastful pride one a classical
tournament but I've been struggling but
before we get to that right they tie for
first right and 3-way player three-way
tie for first of all zone three now
we're expecting the tie break except the
tie break rules turn out to be nice kind
of bad okay three of the greatest chess
players in the world tie for first and
now think of all the great tie breaking
schemes that you might come up with to
draw the best of the best and let them
show their strengths know what we're
gonna do instead is we're gonna draw
straws and the short guy he's out and
the two guys are gonna play for the
title so one guy just gets eliminated
just by without any play at all by the
flip of a coin indeed it was a coin flip
that was
a tie-break with the best players on the
planet and Magnus screamed bloody murder
well that's one whoops the other whoops
and this was much more critical was of
course that the players were trying to
get to London qualifying for London and
one of the winners Fabiano has actually
end up on the grand chest or he's tied
with the exact number of points as
Wesley so so he's got to play a
tie-break to determine the fourth and
final player to London okay now on top
of this keep in mind that London the
World Chess Championship is coming up
it's going to feature Fabiano and Magnus
in that World Championship match and
they're gonna be playing a tiebreaker
well hold your hats everybody this is
gonna be a great show and we'll come
back and we'll give you the tie breaking
the tie breaks and how it all go to work
no discussion Bobby doesn't want to play
two tiebreaks on the same day that's
unfitness says and there's no way I'm
gonna be involved in any coin flip right
it tied for first I get knocked out for
no reason and the tournament arbiters
have to come together and the players
basically they went on strike you made
it over the rule and said this should
not be like this and the arbiter agrees
gives them the option of agreeing to
what should happen at the end which is
pretty remarkable that organisers would
put the hand the power in the hands of
the players right and they agree let's
just call it a tie and we have three
repeat winners you got the trophy at all
the names of the trophy that that want
one person's name with one year one who
did something this is a big batch of
three you know it's really funny because
at the time we're all scratching our
heads and we're wondering what's going
to happen what's going on and then
looking back on it you know it was
really the right decision and I'll tell
you who else was really down with it was
Rex Sinquefield
Rex thought that in a classical chess
tournament
that's okay well it was quite the
brouhaha but it ended with three great
champions finally repeating and another
great chapter in the series that is the
sink oh yeah absolutely